Chace asks how can you stand out on
linkedin with all the chatter from the
social media gurus that are spamming
every one speed chase I took this
question because I need to Razzie you
and everybody else who asks a question
like this but I want you to know that I
love you and I apologize this is a loser
question if you're worried about
everybody else you're not worried about
yourself and that's the bottom line
it is stunning how little I know about
anything else except my world and you
guys period end of story
I don't know how everybody else's
podcast is doing I don't I've not
listened to anybody else's podcast or
video show or anything else I'm aware I
know that I'm between 60 and 80 on the
podcast ratings but I don't look at Tim
Ferriss who's higher or somebody else
and listen to it and try to figure it
out I focus on my stuff way too many
people cry oh these social media gurus
are so loud they're loud but if they
don't have depth they're gonna weed
themselves out and so if you spend one
minute looking at what anybody else is
doing versus spending all your time
about what is your audience care about
and how are they reacting to your stuff
you know what I spend my hour on when
I'm like winding down instead of looking
at whose ratings are higher and then
trying to copy their moves or complain
that they're putting out shows longer or
better or different things or get guests
or this and that
instead of focusing on their context and
their competitive advantages or what
they're doing well what I do is I read
my comments that's what I do because I
really care about what you guys are
saying about this show where the value
prop is what your opinion on the website
is what your opinion about chugging is
what your opinion about banter is
because that's how I'm collectively
trying to make this show better I'm
focusing on the people that give a crap
about this and so instead of worrying
about what everybody else is doing
I don't even scray and I think you can
see my energy on this I know this is a
huge huge you know in lieu of the
marathon coming to New York this weekend
I am NOT a runner who looks around me
I'm like straight ahead that analogy
that people use this not my analogy I
have a lot of my own oh by the way we
are the reverse engineer shirt right
let's link that up that's up did I blow
it you put
on T public and only is like 72 hours
where it's $14 and goes to 22 that's
right so we need to like I need to put a
fit do I have OBS you can I post I need
to put I'm gonna post this on Facebook
it's already up by the time you watch
this cuz D rocks got some editing to do
D right did I ruin your Halloween did we
start too late here like what time is
this gonna be done okay my friends stop
paying attention that everybody else who
gives a [ __ ] I need a lot of beeps in
this episode because I want to keep it
clean for the podcast who gives a crap
what every other social media guru and
expert if they're attracting an audience
maybe they're doing something right it's
not up to you to decide they're a fluffy
crappie guru and they don't deserve it
clearly they're hustling and putting out
stuff and clearly they'll stay don't
forget I've been around since oh six
under this kind of monarchy and this is
the interesting thing there's a lot of
people that were the social media
technology gurus in 2007 8 and 9 that
you've never heard of they come and go
if they're not good enough and if
they're good enough they stay oh crap
wait subscribe I need subscriptions
because I can't push this many right
hooks in social so subscribe